[Música]
y seguimos hablando de economía directo
américa ya sea conmigo nuevamente en el
estudio de las mentes de veces vamos a
hablar entonces de china porque las
acciones de la promotora inmobiliaria
evergrande se desplomaron este lunes así
es raúl y esto ante la posibilidad de
que la empresa caiga en un
incumplimiento de pagos lo que ha
generado que las acciones de esta
organización caigan un 12 por ciento de
estos son los números más bajos de la
empresa en los últimos 11 años la
empresa reconoció durante el pasado fin
de semana que no cuenta con los recursos
necesarios para hacer frente a sus
obligaciones financieras hay que
recordar que desde el pasado mes de
septiembre esta empresa ha estado
revisando su estructura de capital y
posición de liquidez con la ayuda de sus
asesores la situación ha incrementado
los temores de una posible intervención
del estado para mitigar el impacto en la
economía de toda la región ahora pasamos
a europa porque los precios de la
energía se incrementaron hoy lunes esto
de acuerdo con medios como europa press
que cita datos del operador del mercado
ibérico de la electricidad los precios
superaron nuevamente los 200 euros en
españa y en algunos países se acercaron
a trescientos euros por megavatio/hora
de acuerdo con la referida institución
los precios crecieron un 105 73 por
ciento en españa la publicación agrega
que el encarecimiento de los precios de
electricidad en los últimos meses
responde principalmente a los elevados
precios que ha mostrado el gas en este
periodo en otros países de europa como
francia el valor del megavatio ahora
estaría por el orden de los doscientos
82,52 euros al tiempo que en suiza se
ubicó este lunes en 296 a 91 21 euros el
megavatio hay en méxico crece la
preocupación por la posible aprobación
del plan de gastos del presidente yo
vayan louis de acuerdo con el diario el
financiero de esa nación la atención se
ha generado por la posibilidad de que se
ha aprobado este plan de gasto de
llombai de que entre otras cosas prevé
recursos para la compra de autos
eléctricos por ello el gobierno mexicano
a través de su secretaria de economía ha
iniciado contactos senadores
estadounidenses para especificar lo
delicado de la propuesta y esto para las
relaciones económicas entre méxico y
eeuu
la iniciativa de yo para ir en que
requiere de unos 100 1.75 millones de
dólares prevé destinar recursos para
fomentar la compra de autos eléctricos
que en su mayoría son fabricados en eeuu
de acuerdo con la secretaría mexicana
los contactos con los senadores en
estadounidense ya comenzaron vale
recordar que la industria automotriz en
méxico reporte el 4 por ciento del
producto interno bruto y el 25 por
ciento de las exportaciones de esa
nación para tener una idea en 2019
previo a la pandemia y previo también al
entrar en vigor del nuevo tratado
comercial dicho intercambio alcanzó más
de 160 mil millones de dólares pero el
bloque de empresarios ha manifestado
intención de respaldar al gobierno
mexicano en cada una de sus acciones y
este último no descarta responder con
posibles represalias escuchemos
nosotros para defender a nuestra
industria automotriz y la compromiso
regional tomaríamos represalias
comerciales eso lo haríamos porque
porque no se vale no se vale que estemos
jugando
y somos socios cuando me conviene y
cuando no te aplico por la vía este
oscura y digo oscura porque no se nota
porque estamos hablando que esta medida
entraría en vigor en el 2027 en donde se
vuelve importante ver estarían dando que
a lo mejor contexto con esto la pregunta
anterior no es una fuga de capitales si
podría generar el movimiento de plantas
louis ahora hablemos de brasil porque el
presidente ya él bolsonaro se refirió al
precio de los combustibles de acuerdo
con el diario folha de sao paulo el
presidente anunció ayer que la empresa
estatal petrobras podría anunciar en los
próximos días una reducción en el precio
de los combustibles el diario señala que
el presidente hizo el anuncio al medio
poder 360 aunque no ofreció mayores
detalles detalles sobre la noticia para
recordar que en brasil los precios del
combustible han sufrido un aumento a lo
largo de este año debido a que el valor
de esto se está anclado al precio del
barril de petróleo que ha mostrado
incrementos en los últimos meses
indicadores económicos vamos a hablar de
asia porque como ya lo mencionamos el
caso de evergrande ha provocado si
respectos en los principales mercados de
esa región solamente el mercado de corea
del sur cerró con números positivos en
las jornadas en europa continúan las
operaciones con números positivos todo
ello debido a indicadores que han
marcado buenos números de el mes de
noviembre en europa sobre todo el sector
manufacturero y también la venta de
autos en reino unido para finalizar lo
hice este último bloque económico del
día de hoy que nos tiene como cifra la
cifra entidad tiene que ver en este caso
con los mil millones de dólares que ha
sido la recaudación de trump media la
empresa de donald trump de medios de
comunicación que estaría cotizando en
bolsa para la próxima semana raúl otro
dato que te agregó esta empresa es que
ya tiene una valoración cercana a los 4
mil millones de 46 millones y todavía no
está completamente conforma ya no vamos
a ver entonces qué va a pasar con esta
empresa de comunicaciones del
expresidente donald trump les muchísimas
gracias por toda la información
económica nosotros continuamos con más
en los estudios ya está listo rodrigo
sedano para los deportes